schön dass sie dabei sind ich bin auch
gleich bei ihnen ich gucke nur schnell
noch mal ob ich irgendwo am horizont die
inzidenz 35 sehen kann
warte mal an dass die 70 schade
vergesst die 35 die 35 ist als incident
ziel für deutschland ungefähr so
realistisch wie für mich als hosen weite
35 ja wie geht es jetzt weiter
da herrscht eine gewisse ratlosigkeit in
umfragen bröselt das vertrauen in die
bundesregierung regelrecht zusammen und
zwar nicht ganz unverdient aktuelles
beispiel die kostenlosen schnelltests
für alle ab erster märz von jens spahn
versprochen jetzt von der chefin
kassiert hier exklusive bilder von
seiner neuesten demütigung kommt so
rüber auch jungs übrigens du brauchst
nächste woche nicht zum friseur
wieso wollte dir dein schnell das
konzept in die haare schön kanns ja ist
kanzlerin humor muss man dabei gewesen
sein
er hatte wohl sein konzept vorher nicht
mal mit den apotheken abgeklärt
gesundheitsminister sparen ist offiziell
jens unten meine damen und herren jens
unten angekommen in großbritannien
spendiert der staat vielen unternehmen
grad ist es für alle mitarbeiter
warum kann deutschland das nicht wir
stehen wir dann plötzlich da europaweit
wird in zypern und österreich am meisten
getestet auch frankreich liegt im
vorderen drittel deutschland auf platz
zwischen der slowakei und ungarn
also ich sags ungarn aber das ist
peinlich peinlich platz 22 willkommen
beim esc man hatte monate zeit
massenhaft schnelltests zu kaufen wenn
der staat seine hausaufgaben machen
würde hätten die ganzen durchhalte
appell an uns bürger deutlich mehr
gewicht marokko hat uns inzwischen beim
impfen überholt marokko und hier stapelt
sich unvernünftig astrazeneca gibt's
doch alles nicht von den machern des
impfte bakels kommt jetzt die versendete
test strategie nur mit viel testen gibt
es überhaupt wieder hoffnung für
einzelhandel oder kultur und die
anwendung ist kinderleicht
öffnen sie den behälter machen sie ein
laut aus tiefster kehle um dort den
speicher zu lösen dann spucken sie
speicher in den behälter sie hatten
einen kommentar zur aktuellen groko
performance man möchte in einer tour
kroate machen wir stehen möglicherweise
am anfang einer dritten welle
das heißt ja in der konsequenz entweder
noch härterer lockdown mit den
entsprechenden kollateralschäden oder
mit klugen modernen lösungen wieder
einen hauch normalität ermöglichen
gibt es da vielleicht schon ideen das
ist ein aspekt schnelltests der nächste
ist alle technischen möglichkeiten zu
nutzen
ich hab halt morgen mit smudo
telefoniert aha der sänger von rammstein
ist nicht ran gegangen als er armins
nummer gesehen hat übrigens smudo hat
tatsächlich mit wissenschaftlern eine
app entwickelt für die kontakt
nachverfolgung bei konzerten oder im
einzelhandel exakt so was brauchen wir
und zwar jetzt genau wie die tests
massenhaft testen wer super wichtig
bevor man zb schulen wieder aufmacht
achhammer schon wieder aufgemacht
versteh nur dann lasst uns mal das beste
hoffen
in manchen bundesländern werden lehrer
ab und zu getestet regelmäßige tests für
schüler fehlanzeige
im grünen eine art menschenversuch ja
ist ja so sicher es darf keine verlorene
schüler generation entstehen aber man
hätte doch vorher mindest standards
vereinbaren müssen
für tests für luftreiniger und natürlich
wird sie nicht überraschen macht jetzt
wieder jeder was er will
in berliner grundschulen masken pflicht
in niedersachsen nicht immer in
thüringen nur in monaten ohne ermal
wechsel unterricht mal präsenz und so
sieht's in sachsen aus versetzte
ankunftszeiten getrennte eingänge
doch am ende sitzen alle wieder in einer
klasse
ob diese maßnahmen ausreichen ja ich
weiß es die antwort ist nein war zu
einfach
immerhin steht in der sächsischen corona
schutzverordnung in kreisen mit
incidents über 100 gibt es keinen
präsenzunterricht mehr nur und jetzt
kommt diese regel gilt erst ab dem 8
märz bis dahin bleiben zb die schulen im
vogtlandkreis offen bei stand mittwoch
incidents 171 das ist mutig denn das
setzt ja voraus dass sich das virus an
die korona schutzverordnung hält und bis
zum 8 märz keinen ansteckt dazu begrüßt
sich kurz die britische mutante können
wir uns darauf verlassen will auf kurs
die britische mutter die wort fairness
ist eine britische erfindung wenn die
verordnung steht akte märz actiware cds
sorry ich hab mich bei südafrika
angesteckt das tut mir leid gute
besserung
ja ich fürchte da kommt noch allerhand
nerviges homeschooling auf uns zu aber
selbst das kann man positiv sehen wenn
man unbedingt muss das alles ist aus der
krise dieser pandemie geboren aber wir
können uns auch als rückenwind 10
rückenwind den wir nutzen wollen um der
digitalen bildung in deutschland einen
kräftigen schub zu verleihen
was die sich traut die selbe frau die 16
jahre die digitalisierung verpennt hat
sagt jetzt corona ist auch eine
riesenchance ohne rot zu werden
rückenwind wir halten fest in vielen
bundesländern haben die grundschulen
noch auf mein tipp nutzen sie das
zeitfenster
liebe eltern jetzt ist eure zeit die
kinder sind in der schule ein bad am
vormittag war in nord noch mal alle
folgen game of thrones weg wünschen und
sich dabei schön einen ball an
na klar oder einfach die ruhe genießen
ohne sinnloses gekreische jetzt die
schlechte nachricht
spätestens in zwei wochen geht die kurve
hoch und der kinderklasse macht wieder
zu also denkt dran
eure zeit gerecht denn schon in wenigen
tagen sind die beladen wieder zu hause
[Musik]
wirklich die dritte welle könnte groß
werden aber der lockerungs druck ist
größer
schon vor dem gipfel nächste woche
lockern die länderchefs um die wette und
das verblüffendste markus söder lockert
mit ja in bayern öffnen nicht nur die
friseure sondern auch baumärkte und der
garten bedarf ist söder neulich noch
team vorsicht plötzlich im team locker
christian ehring leitet in münchen dass
markus söder institut für
krisenkommunikation haring ist da etwa
einer umgefallen 1 markus söder fällt
nicht um das mal klar ist ja das geht
physikalisch überhaupt nicht wenn
überhaupt dann legt er sich von alleine
hin und zwar aus gründen in einer
aktuellen umfrage sind seine
zustimmungswerte in bayern um 20
prozentpunkte in den keller gegangen es
ist eine katastrophe
natürlich muss er locker nur drückt er
es halt viel cooler aus als seine doofen
kollegen
wir brauchen nämlich keine lockerungen
wir brauchen achtung
wir brauchen eine intelligente öffnungs
matrix keinen starren stufenplan aber
eine öffnungs matrix eröffnungs matrix
ich habe den film direkt vor augen das
plakat ist schon fertig piano söder in
die öffnungs matrix da eröffnete er
gnadenlos ein gartencenter in
unterhaching
kaffee ist alles drin sex gewalt
stiefmütterchen das ist aktives
krisenmanagement söders teil das können
sie bei uns am institut lernen es gibt
drei goldene regeln
erstens ständig so viel die konkurrenz
dissen einfach damit klar ist wer den
längsten hat wie man um die menschen
weniger sorge als vielmehr um die um die
um die nervosität in der politik spürbar
die politik ist nervöser als die
menschen im moment und der ein oder
andere verliert auch vielleicht die
nerven verstehen sie die anderen
verlieren die nerven fangen an zu heulen
stellen sich ein
während ein markus söder
unerschütterlich stehen bleibt im sturm
der ereignisse wie ein die wie ein
bajuwarischer raumteiler der eisern sein
ding durchziehen mit einem ruhepuls von
kurze zwischenfrage ist söder nicht auch
die politik ruhe die zeit haben wenn ich
regel zwei direkte demokratie wagen
gerade in krisenzeiten muss der bürger
mitreden dürfen übrigens meine haare
wachsen auch unendlich wird man übrigens
mal interessieren vielleicht könnt ihr
da mal eine resonanz geben sondern sie
länger lassen also bis auf die furcht
bankrott retten sollen dass er länger
lassen oder lieber wieder kürzer
feedback wer ganz spannend seitdem wird
ununterbrochen feedback gemailt hier
schreibt zum beispiel an franz-josef 69
mach dir von mir aus einem mini coupe
interessiert doch keine sau aber es
kommen auch viele positive rückmeldungen
unten irgendwo ist ja auch egal regel
nummer drei mit total natürlich
wirkenden kunstpausen nachdenklichkeit
simulieren
wunderbar dadurch wirkt er neuerdings so
sensibel aber es ist für den heutigen
tag ein sehr sehr gutes und vor allem
schnelles zwischenergebnis trotzdem ist
die stimmung schwierig weihnachten ist
eigentlich das wichtigste festival wie
geht es jetzt weiter
keiner macht so geile pausen keiner
wegen mir keiner insgesamt mal pause
machen
es glaubt doch kein mensch diese neue
nachdenklichkeit das übt er doch mit
ihnen forum spiegel herr welke
nun ist es ja so die stimmung
weihnachten mir reicht's christian ehre
in vielen dank
also bei aller ehrlichen freude für die
gartenfans nicht zuletzt die kultur
braucht endlich auch meine perspektive
viele freischaffende künstler sind in
hartz4 gefallen oder schlagen sich mit
irgendwelchen anderen jobs durch die
realität diese woche haben
wissenschaftler immerhin vorschläge
gemacht und veröffentlicht wie man
kultur und sport langsam wieder
hochfahren könnte zeit wird's meint auch
friedemann weise
friedemann weise rettet die deutsche
kultur
[Musik]
endlich mal wieder auf einer bühne
stehen
auch wenn es nur bei der heute show ist
man nimmt er im moment was man kriegen
kann ist eine wirklich schwere zeit für
uns bühnen menschen umso wichtiger dass
die politik um die bedeutung der kultur
weiß für viele menschen betrifft es fast
ihre körperliche gesundheit ja ist doch
so ohne kultur
wer was ich höre da ging es um friseure
aber passt auch meine locker und frisur
ist ein sinnbild für den zustand der
kultur in deutschland so sah ich vor der
pandemie aus zum glück hat sich die
kanzlerin von anfang an darum gekümmert
dass unser kulturelles leben auch in
zukunft eine chance hat und dass
künstlerinnen und künstlern brücken
gebaut werden
gut brücken müssen jetzt gar nicht sein
geld würde vielen schon reichen
davon kann nämlich bei den meisten
bisher viel zu wenig an
in dem konzept das die wissenschaft für
kultur und sport geschrieben hat kam
unter anderem heraus dass eine fahrt mit
der bahn dreimal so riskant ist wie ein
opernbesuch klingt erstmal gut aber
versuch mal mit der oper von köln nach
frankfurt zu kommen
das konzept sieht vor dass bei indoor
veranstaltungen erst mal nur 25 bis 30
prozent der stühle besetzt werden das
heißt für die meisten künstler ändert
sich gar nichts
natürlich braucht man auch eine
priorisierung liste wie beim impfen
zuerst dürfen hier auf die bühne die
sowieso mal ausgetragen danach kommen
pantomime
die stehen ja immer hinter einer
glaswand dann alle anderen und als
allerletztes puppenspieler aber das hat
persönliche gründe
bei dem konzept ging es hauptsächlich um
großveranstaltungen will man da die
abstandsregeln einhalten ohne die
besucherzahl zu reduzieren braucht man
natürlich viel mehr platz ich habe das
mal ausgerechnet wenn bei rock am ring
80.000 leute sind und jeder ein meter
fünfzig abstand hält dann geht das
festival bis duisburg unter umständen
weißt du gar nicht dass du gerade auf
rock am ring bist wirst du merkst du sie
erst wenn ihr bier über den kopf kriegt
aber eins ist doch klar wir brauchen
bald wieder kulturveranstaltungen und
bis dahin müssen wir die
kulturschaffenden unterstützen denn wenn
es keine können
da ihnen mehr gibt und kultur in die
hände der falschen gerät dann sieht eine
großveranstaltung ganz schnell mal so
aus
[Applaus]
und das kann doch wirklich keiner wollen
na ja genau ja ja die zuschauer
mittlerweile fast alle versteckten
symbole bei uns im neuen studio gefunden
illuminati freimaurer staatsführung ist
alles dabei dann wollen wir denn die
eigentlichen strippenzieher bekannt
geben dass so viele abonnenten auf
youtube also ich würde mich ran halten